Muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos un vídeo
hablando sobre Rumanía. Y es que, por sorprendente
que os parezca, hay muchos rumanos que siguen
este canal. Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué?
Lo cierto es que Rumanía es el país de origen
de la mayoría de los inmigrantes que hay
en España. Mucho más que cualquier otro
país hispanoparlante. Tal cual como lo oís.
España es el hogar de más de 750.000 rumanos.
Y además, el rumano es un idioma muy parecido
al español, así que todos estos inmigrantes
se integran con relativa facilidad y en seguida
aprenden a hablar un perfecto castellano,
como si fueran del mismo Valladolid.
¡Pero no sólo eso! Además, tenemos que
hablar de Rumanía porque puede convertirse
en la primera democracia del mundo en legalizar
la corrupción.
¡Habéis oído bien! En enero de 2017, el
parlamento rumano aprobó un decreto en el
que se permitía que los políticos aceptaran
sobornos por valor de hasta 44.000 euros.
Sin que nadie pudiera juzgarles.
Como os podéis imaginar, este decreto ha
desatado las mayores protestas que haya conocido
este país en los últimos 20 años. El gobierno
ha tenido que retirar, temporalmente, este
decreto. Pero aún así, las protestas continúan.
Los rumanos estaban demasiado acostumbrados
a vivir en el país más corrupto de toda
la Unión Europea. Y este decreto de la vergüenza
ha sido la gota que ha colmado el vaso.
Pero la pregunta es ¿Cómo han llegado hasta
aquí? ¿Qué pasa en un país para que su
gobierno se atreva a sacar semejantes leyes
con este descaro? Hoy vamos a responder a
esta pregunta, pero antes, vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
No se puede entender la historia de Rumanía
sin conocer antes a Nicoláe Ceaucescu: el
Kim Jon Un Europeo. Otros países de la zona
como Hungría o Bulgaria también han sufrido
dictaduras comunistas. Pero el caso de Rumanía
es especial.
Desde que CEAUCESCU llegó al poder en 1974,
su país se aisló del resto del mundo. Incluso
de la propia Unión Soviética. Pronto los
alimentos empezaron a escasear. Pero mientras
a los ciudadanos se les racionaba la comida,
Ceaucescu se gastaba el dinero público en
construirse palacios faraónicos. Para que
os hagáis una idea, el Parlamento de Bucarest,
construído en 1983, es el más grande de
todo el mundo. Esto es sorprendente si tenemos
en cuenta que Rumanía tiene poco más de
22 millones de habitantes. Pero es que además,
se estima que durante las obras, se emplearon
a más de 20.000 trabajadores, de los cuales
3000 murieron de extenuación.
¡No sólo eso! Además Chauchescu obligaba
a sus ciudadanos a que participaran en desfiles
y todo tipo de espectáculos masivos organizados
para ensalzar su propia imagen.
Y al igual que sus compañeros norcoreanos,
Ceaucescu era un auténtico maestro en el
arte de la represión política. Durante los
años 80, se estima que 1 de cada 30 rumanos
pertenecía a la policía política. Podían
ser tu vecino o tu peluquero. Y si en algún
momento se te ocurría decir algo en contra
del gran líder podías terminar en una cárcel
o, simplemente, desaparecer.
Sin embargo, y pese a todo esto, la profesión
de dictador es un trabajo más arriesgado
de lo que parece.
Estas imágenes que veis pertenecen al último
discurso de CEAUCESCU, el 21 de diciembre
de 1989. Fijaros en la expresión de su cara
y cómo la cámara empieza a temblar… ¡Justo
ese es el momento en el que el público empezó
a abuchearlo.
Así es como comenzaron las mayores protestas
hasta la fecha en la historia de Rumanía.
Miles de ciudadanos se lanzaron a las calles
con banderas rumanas a las que les habían
recortado los símbolos comunistas. Y 3 días
después, concretamente el día de Navidad
de ese mismo año, Nicolae CEAUCESCU moría
junto a su mujer, a manos de sus propios compañeros
de partido. Sus últimas palabras fueron “La
historia me vengará”.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Qué pasó después?
Lo cierto es que en un régimen tan opresor
como el de Ceaucescu, no existía ninguna
fuerza opositora. Por hacer una comparación,
en Polonia, cuando cae el régimen comunista,
ya existía una fuerza de oposición, dirigida
por Les Walesa, con suficiente apoyo social
como para llegar al gobierno y redactar una
nueva constitución. Sin embargo ¿Quién
creéis que sucedió a Ceaucescu en Rumanía?
¡Efectivamente! Sus propios compañeros de
partido. Más concretamente, este hombre que
veis aquí, que se llamaba IÓN ILIESCU.
Como os podéis imaginar, este nuevo gobierno
no estaba dispuesto a perder todos esos lujos
que habían vivido durante la época de Ceaucescu.
Así que, como siempre pasa en estos casos,
el régimen rumano cambio… ¡Pero sólo
un poquito! Por supuesto que la nueva constitución
admitía que otros partidos pudieran presentarse
a las elecciones. Y el antiguo partido comunista
cambió de nombre y pasó a llamarse Partido
Socialdemócrata. Pero los mismos altos cargos
que estaban gobernando con Ceaucescu siguieron
teniendo el poder durante los años 90 y 2000.
Y como ya sabéis, si el poder corrompe, el
poder absoluto corrompe absolutamente. Para
que os hagáis una idea: en 1995, el 50% de
la economía de Polonia ya eran empresas privadas.
En Rumanía, sólo un 35%.
¿Queréis un ejemplo? Vamos a coger dos fabricantes
de coches. En Checoslovaquia tenían una fábrica
estatal, SKODA. Esta empresa se privatizó
en 1992 repartiendo los títulos de propiedad
entre los trabajadores. Su equivalente rumano,
DACIA, no se privatizó hasta 1997. Y en lugar
de hacerlo mediante reparto, el Gobierno lo
vendió al Grupo RENAULT.
En otras palabras, durante los 90 y los 2000,
los distintos gobiernos rumanos hicieron todo
lo que pudieron para mantener el control de
la economía y el país. Sólo así podían
continuar con sus corruptelas sin que nadie
les pudiera controlar.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque la corrupción
también estaba a pequeño nivel! En un país
tan acostumbrado a la escasez, era imposible
conseguir nada sin hacer un pequeño soborno
¿Quieres que te atienda el médico? Regálale
un cartón de tabaco ¿Quieres tener electricidad
en casa? ¡Una botella de whisky y unos billetes
y asunto arreglado! Así es como un país
entero hizo de la corrupción, un sistema
de vida.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Puede funcionar así
un país? Lo cierto es que no. Los rumanos
veían cómo otras repúblicas ex soviéticas
como Chequia o Polonia empezaban a tener estándares
de vida occidentales mientras ellos continuaban
malviviendo con menos de 400 dólares al mes.
Y por eso, a mediados de los años 2000, Rumanía
solicita la entrada en la Unión Europea para
poder recibir fondos europeos. Y Bruselas
dice “vale, te dejo entrar, pero con una
condición”… Y esa condición es…
En el año 2002, el gobierno rumano funda
una agencia para perseguir la corrupción,
el Directorio Nacional Anticorrupción, o
como se le conoce habitualmente, el DNA. Durante
los primeros años, esta agencia estaba dirigida
por fiscales afines al partido. Así que era
una forma de decir “que sí, Bruselas ¿Ves?
Estoy limpiando el país de corruptos”.
Pero, de Nuevo, ningún cambio.
Hasta el año 2013. En ese momento es cuando
entra en escena una mujer dispuesta a enfrentarse
a todo y a todos: LAURA KODRUTA KOVESI.
“Los rumanos parecen impresionados con las
actividades del DNA: según una encuesta,
el 60% de la población dice que confía en
la agencia mientras que sólo el 11% confía
en el parlamento”
En solo 2 años, Kovesi ha metido en la carcel
a más de 1100 políticos acusados de casos
de corrupción. Durante estos años, los rumanos
han descubierto todos los tejemanejes que
se traía su clase política ¡Y no son pocos!
Según estimaciones, la corrupción en Rumanía
supone, nada menos, que el 15% de su Producto
Interior Bruto. Prácticamente todos los contratos
públicos tienen algún tipo de soborno. Incluso
las licencias de Microsoft que usan los funcionarios
rumanos llevan un sobrecoste de hasta 3 millones
de euros que se fueron en sobornos a distintos
oficiales del gobierno. Una jueza, por ejemplo,
llegó a cobrar el equivalente a 630.000 euros
por declarar inocente a un criminal. Y así
una lista interminable de casos. Desde el
año 2013, todos esos delincuentes están
llenando las cárceles de este país. Hasta
tal punto, que muchas prisiones ya no tienen
espacio para más presos.
¡Pero no sólo eso! La propia sociedad rumana
se ha dado cuenta de lo importante que es
la corrupción. Pero las cosas empezaron a
tomar otro cariz con esta noticia.
“Un incendio en un club de Bucarest deja
27 muertos y varios heridos”
Esta noticia desató una oleada de protestas
en toda Rumanía. Al parecer, este incendio
se hubiera evitado si el club cumpliera con
las regulaciones anti incendios. Pero resulta
que el dueño del local había sobornado a
las autoridades de turno para que le dejaran
abrir sin cumplir con las normas. Y así es
como surgió la plataforma CORUPTIA UCHIDE:
“LA CORRUPCIÓN MATA”. A través de las
redes sociales, los rumanos comenzaron a organizarse
en grupos de protesta en contra de la corrupción.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque todavía
queda lo mejor!
El 18 de enero de 2017, a las 10 de la noche,
el Ejecutivo socialdemócrata, con el primer
ministro, SORIN GRINDEANU a la cabeza, aprueba
un decreto de urgencia. Y sí, lo hace a las
10 de la noche, cuando todo el mundo está
en sus casas a punto de meterse en la cama.
¿Y qué decía ese decreto? Pues que, a partir
de ese momento, aquellos políticos que hayan
aceptado sobornos por valor inferior a 44.000
euros, no tienen que ir a la cárcel. Ni pagar
ninguna multa. Como si no hubieran hecho nada
malo, vaya. Para más INRI, este decreto se
presenta durante el debate de los presupuestos.
Es decir, que lo intentan sacar de tapadillo,
sin que nadie se entere.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero a quién se le ocurre
sacar semejante decreto con tanto descaro?
Es decir ¿Cuál es el argumento oficial para
descriminalizar el cobro de sobornos? Pues
bien, esta es la razón que daba el Primer
Ministro rumano, Sorin Grindeanu:
“Quiere aprobar este decreto para evitar
la superpoblación en las prisiones”
(silencio de unos segundos) Sí, este es el
argumento que ha dado el Gobierno de Rumanía.
Tal cual. Es más, según las estimaciones
que dan las autoridades de prisiones, con
este decreto se liberarían a más de 3000
políticos corruptos. Y lo cierto es que algunas
cárceles rumanas tienen superoblación. Eso
es un hecho. Pero en un país donde el dinero
se escapa en sobrecostes y sobornes, no debería
ser ningún problema construir nuevas prisiones.
Y además, el hecho de que la mayoría de
los políticos convictos pertenezcan al partido
del gobierno es un tanto sospechoso ¿No os
parece?
Lo mismo pensaron los más de 500.000 rumanos
que se lanzaron a las calles de Bucarest minutos
después de que se aprobara este decreto.
A través de la plataforma “La corrupción
mata”, los ciudadanos se enteraron en seguida
de la noticia. Y no les hizo mucha gracia.
Así es como surgió la mayor protesta de
la historia
de Rumanía.
“Nunca pensé que esto sería posible. Siempre
pensaba que había una lógica, un sentido
común, detrás de cada ley… pero ahora
que ha pasado esto, veo que me equivocaba”
Las protestas se alargaron durante varios
días. No sólo en Bucarest sino en prácticamente,
todas las ciudades de este país. Y la primera
víctima de este malestar fue el Ministro
de Justicia, que se vio obligado a dimitir
el 9 de febrero de 2017. El Gobierno, además,
ha tenido que retirar ese decreto, aunque
ya han dicho que lo hacen de forma temporal.
Y el nuevo ministro de justicia, TUDOREL TOADER
tiene una misión muy clara: justificar el
despido del fiscal general y de la directora
del DNA, nuestra amiga LAURA KODRUTA KOVESI:
la mujer que ha metido en la cárcel a más
de mil políticos. Desde el gobierno, aseguran
que esta agencia anti corrupción está haciendo
una caza de brujas. Pero, con la ley en la
mano, todavía no han encontrado ningún mecanismo
para conseguir echarla.
“Tras evaluar todos los factores constitucionales,
legales y de oportunidad, he decidido que,
por el momento, no es aconsejable empezar
los mecanismos institucionales para revocar
al fiscal general y a la fiscal jefe del DNA”
Mientras tanto, el Gobierno de Grindeanu está
acorralado por dos lados: por un lado, la
sociedad civil les está vigilando todos los
movimientos. Por el otro la Unión Europea
le exige que haga limpieza y que deje de entorpecer
el trabajo de los fiscales anticorrupción.
Y por supuesto, estas élites políticas,
que son herederas del régimen de Ceaucescu,
recurren a las clásicas teorías conspiranoicas
para defenderse. Según ellos, todas estas
protestas están orquestadas por George Soros
y la familia Rothchild. Según ellos, la corrupción
no es un problema tan grabe en Rumanía.
Con o sin conspiraciones, estamos hablando
de toda una crisis existencial en el tercer
país más pobre de toda Europa.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que Rumanía
debería encarcelar a todos esos políticos
corruptos para poder estar a la altura del
resto de países europeos? ¿O pensáis que,
efectivamente, el gobierno de Grindeanu hace
bien en despenalizar los sobornos? Podéis
dejarme la respuesta en los comentarios.
Y si queréis conocer otro caso de revolución
ciudadana, podéis echar un vistazo a este
otro vídeo donde Couto os cuenta lo que es
la Revolución de los Paraguas en HONG KONG.
Haced click aquí para verlo.
Y por supuesto, no olvidéis que sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas. Así que suscribios
al canal para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones. Si os ha gustado este vídeo,
dadle a LIKE y nos vemos en el próximo! Un
abrazo y hasta pronto!